enhancements in cryptographic key
encryption
a partnership between ibm and confluent
and the beta of ibm cloud app
configuration
all on this episode of ibm cloud now
what's up y'all my name is ian and i am
back
to bring you the latest and greatest
news and announcements from ibm cloud
last week ibm announced a series of
cloud services and technologies that are
designed to help clients maintain the
highest available level
of cryptographic key encryption
protection this both helps
protect existing data in the cloud and
prepares for future threats that it
could evolve
with advances in quantum computing
pioneered by ibm research scientists
we are now offering quantum safe
cryptography support for key management
and application transactions in ibm
cloud
this gives us the industry's most
holistic quantum save crypto approach
to securing data through the use of
open standards and open source
technology this service enhances the
standards used to transmit data
between enterprise and cloud helping to
secure data
by using a quantum safe algorithm we're
also excited to announce extended
capabilities for ibm cloud hyper protect
crypto services
these new capabilities are available to
enhance privacy of data in cloud
applications
and are supported by keep your own key
capabilities
to learn more about this announcement
please see the press release i've got
linked in the description of this video
okay next up we've got a new partnership
between ibm and confluent
the original creators of apache kafka
ibm is excited to now offer confluent
platform
as an add-on to the ibm cloud pack for
integration
confluent platform complements kafka
with advanced capabilities that are
designed to help accelerate application
development
enable digital transformation and
simplify enterprise operations at scale
together ibm cloud pack for integration
and confluent platform
can help you unlock and take advantage
of the enormous amounts of data
generated by events allowing you to
deliver engaging customer experiences
and drive business innovation to learn
more about this partnership
and how it can benefit you see the link
i've got below and sign up for the
webinar coming in january
to wrap things up this episode i want to
shine a light on ibm cloud app
configuration
a new beta service for centralized
feature management
and configuration app configuration is a
really helpful tool for developers
app owners and devops engineers among
the many features
are the ability to centralize
configurations use dark launch target
features and configurations to segments
roll out features apart from deployments
and detect problems and instantly roll
back
to try out the beta of ibm cloud app
configuration and learn more
see the link below thanks so much for
joining me today for this episode of ibm
cloud now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics i've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video
and again please don't forget to
subscribe to our channel to stay up to
date on what's going on in the cloud
now